What are your thoughts about guidance?
Guide us to steam up for lower each other. Yes, that there are some.
We have some products in.
What's the name of one product? I forgot it's called.
There are some different products on the market.
Daxinal, diaxinal, that's the product. It's an orthomolecular product.
And it has
bortagelle and
buccal polysaccharides and hyaluronic acid.
There are multiple different products to lower blood sugar.
All of them are just fine.
Crobium, picolidate is another one that was really hot for a long time.
So you can try those things too.
I just like burberry because it has so many other side benefits.